podemos expresar un sinfín de emociones
a través de nuestros cuerpos pero
realmente me encanta utilizar la
articulación para hacer caras expresivas
es fascinante aprender cómo nuestras
caras muestran emociones o ideas hay
muchísimo detalle en cada expresión en
nuestro siguiente ejercicio
articularemos la cara de un muñeco de
nieve y usaremos algunos nuevos de
formadores para lograrlo primero
agreguemos un modificador de escala
direccional un modificador de escala
direccional nos permite modificar la
escala en una sola dirección si
modificamos la escala del sombrero
utilizando modificar escala y
obtendremos un sombrero más alto como un
sombrero de copa si modificamos la
escala de la cara con modificar escala x
obtendremos una cara más ancha también
necesitaremos de formadores de la de los
de formadores de la de o son similares a
los modificadores de escala direccional
en el sentido de que trabajan en una
dirección específica también tenemos
nuestro conjunto de formadores de
rotación traslación y modificación de
escala que ya utilizamos como antes
debes trabajar de boceto a final primero
gira la cabeza y luego traslada y gira
el sombrero
recuerda que el orden de los de
formadores es importante así que prueba
tus controles conforme trabajas cuando
hayas terminado de articular la cabeza
pasa a la siguiente lección donde
aprenderás a escribir código para hacer
tu propio personaje